musique
forcément cela fait écho à l'actualité
dans un hôtel de luxe cette gangster
sont encerclés par la police ils ont
kidnappé puis étrangler la fille d'un
millionnaire
ils n'ont pas de doute sur leur issue
ils savent qu'ils vont mourir
un texte que jean-genais a écrit en 1948
et qu'il n'a jamais vu publier de son
vivant
un spectacle esthétique très physique
une tension palpable même si aucun
acteur ne se touche
c'est ça qui est intéressant
ça veut dire qu'il faut maintenir une
grande tension c'est comme un ruban
qu'on tire qu'on tire qu'on tire
continuer
il ne faut jamais lâcher si on lâche
Xavier le seul qui ne soit pas voyou
dans le spectacle
il interprète un flic qui se rallie à la
cause des gangsters et pour lui jouer du
jeunesse c'est une évidence
ce qui est fascinant chez lui je trouve
c'est son aspect subversif c'est la
personnalité de sa langue son rapport
étrange à la langue française qui est à
la fois
archaïque et en même temps très poétique
il y a une violence une violence qui est
contenue par la le langage et qui grâce
au langage et transformer dans une par
une grande douceur sur que c'est cette
opposition entre la violence rentrée et
la douceur des mots
un texte fort un huis clos oppressant et
toujours cette fascination pour la mort
splendide de Jean Genet marquera sans
aucun doute la saison 2015 du Centre
dramatique d'Orléans